in the middle of the Turkmenistan desert
is it 230 foot wide hole and the hole
it's on fire in 1971 a group of Soviet
petroleum geologists set out across the
desert of Turkmenistan and they were on
the hunt for petroleum and when they
found a place that they thought would be
full of oil they decided to set up a
drilling rig unfortunately for them they
set this drilling rig up over what
turned out to be an enormous cavern of
natural gas and when they punched in
through the top of the desert the entire
thing collapsed taking the drilling rig
with it and even more problematic than
that is now leaking from this gigantic
hole was methane gas which is a
potentially deadly and definitely super
explosive gas so the Soviet geologists
did what was for them the sensible thing
they lit the hole on fire the scientists
thought when they lit this crater on
fire that it would burn for a few weeks
maybe a few months and then it would
just extinguish itself it has been
burning for over 40 years
locals call this the gates of Hell or
the door to hell or more scientifically
the darwaza gas crater in 2009 the
Turkmen president declared that he
wanted the gates of Hell closed kappa it
was an embarrassment to the country but
that hasn't happened and in fact the
gates of Hell have become a kind of
tourist site even the Minister of
Tourism
now cites it as one of their major
attractions and for a country that only
sees between ten and fifteen thousand
tourists a year it's a big deal that
people are excited to go to the gates of
hell it's also said that the Creator
attracts local spiders drawn to the
light and the heat which come to the
edge of the crater and then
throw themselves into it presumably they
are trying to reunite themselves with
their Dark Lord
so the crater has been burning for 40
years and there's no telling when it
will stop but with continued tourist
interest it's likely that it may be
burning for some time to come
subscribe here and watch more videos
here